un piquet de grève qui ne faiblit pas
depuis ce lundi ses ouvriers bloquent
l'accès de la filiale green solutions de
general electric à villeurbanne avec des
pneus et des braseros
ils s'opposent à la suppression de 630
emplois au total sur les cinq sites du
groupe en france le groupe américain
projette de délocaliser la production en
chine et en italie pour des raisons
économiques
un motif qui ne tient pas selon les
salariés et les syndicats n'est pas
acceptable qu'il y ait 2 185 603 sur
villeurbanne pour une usine qui gagnent
de l'argent
on est dans un sens un ps qui tenait
depuis deux ans et la direction n'a pas
repris les skis été négocié il ya un an
donc à la fois la direction a recommencé
son plan à 0 donc il n'est pas
acceptable non plus d'avoir des mesures
sociales qui sont qui sont partis de
zéro
lusine de villeurbanne serait la plus
touchée plus de 250 personnes pourraient
perdre leur travail
cette décision inquiète le maire de la
ville qui a également une espèce
d'indécence social à mettre en place ce
plan
pendant cette période de confinement si
difficile pour les salariés pour les
personnes qui ont des revenus modestes
est dans une phase de grande inquiétude
il ne me semble pas opportun de
continuer ces négociations en tout cas
en l'état actuel c'est pour ça que j'ai
écrit au ministre bruno le maire pour
lui demander de suspendre les plans
sociaux pendant cette période une grève
marquée par la présence de françois
ruffin député la france insoumise de la
somme venus soutenir les grévistes ce
mercredi qui sont les victimes ici
fusion les salariés évidemment c'est la
souveraineté nationale puis que ça
concerne le nucléaire et c'est peut-être
simplement des pièces il n'aura plus à
disposition
c'est enfin la planète puisqu'il ya la
possibilité de recherche et
développement sur les rings ya sept huit
qui seront effectuées voilà moi
malheureusement
j'entends ici ce que j'entends ailleurs
je demande que fait le gouvernement
me répond rien walou les grévistes at
elle jean luc mélenchon le président du
groupe la france un soumise à
l'assemblée nationale à se rendre sur
leur site
dans les jours qui viennent il pourrait
se déplacer à paris pour se faire
entendre de bruno le maire le ministre
de l'économie